[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour
votre numéro dédié à vos idées sorties
tout de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi
22 juin ce week-end vivait une course
automobile en miniature le modélisme
maurepas club accueille une manche du
championnat de france de course de
voitures radiocommandées son président
thierry tanoh nous parlera de cette
discipline
le talent d'aiguillon pour toi à
l'honneur jusqu'au 3 juillet
l'exposition sortie d'atelier nous fait
découvrir les oeuvres réalisées durant
l'année par les élèves des clubs et
associations de nombreux ateliers sont
aussi proposées au public et enfin en
cette période de coupe du monde de
football les plus jeunes peuvent eux
aussi participé de chez eux
mélanie va nous apprendre à créer un
baby-foot maison une activité ludique à
faire en famille
une promenade féerique dans les jardins
du château de versailles les grandes
zones nocturnes ont repris tous les
samedis soirs d'été jusqu'au 15
septembre
bosquet et fontaine se parent de leurs
plus belles lumières sur la musique du
roi soleil et ce samedi soir est
exceptionnel c'est le grand bal masqué
du château à 23h30
venez en costumes baroques pour une nuit
décalé dans l'orangerie danseurs
performeurs et artistes animeront le bal
jusqu'à l'aube
costumes et masques obligatoire la
recherche d'un monde meilleur c'est le
thème de la 7e édition du festival les
images vagabonde
les spectateurs peuvent voir ou revoir
des films autour du sujet comme tron ou
bienvenue à gattaca plusieurs
bibliothèques centres de loisirs et
cinéma des yvelines y participent
jusqu'au 13 juillet c'est le cas à saint
cyr l'école le cinéma les yeux d'elsa
projettera dimanche 1er juillet le film
d'animation wall-e il y aura également
un atelier fabrique ton robot on regarde
tout de suite un extrait de la bande
annonce voici walid
après toutes ces longues années il a
développé un petit défaut technique une
forte personnalité il est extrêmement
curieux et un petit peu trop seul
mais tout cela est sur le point de
changer
[Musique]
auj
non
[Musique]
ce week-end plus de 200 pilotes
s'élanceront sur le circuit du modélisme
maurepas club des pilotes de voitures
radiocommandées
le club accueille une manche du
championnat de france avec nous tirer
dano président du modélisme à maurepas
club bonjour alors c'est la première
fois depuis vingt trois ans qui vous
accueillez une manche du championnat de
france dans cette catégorie de voitures
en tout cas vous attendiez avec
impatience on imagine oui tout à fait
alors on se prépare depuis deux ans déjà
pour essayer de d'après d'accueillir
cette épreuve là on a eu quelques
démarches avec la fédération française
de voitures radiocommandées qui nous a
permis de mettre en place un certain
nombre d'évolutions sur notre circuit
pour qu'ils soient aux normes et qui
répondent à toutes les règles que dicte
la fédération et aujourd'hui on est prêt
et demain on accueille une belle épreuve
du championnat de france
alors justement comment est ce que vous
allez préparer la piste pour accueillir
cette compétition il ya eu lieu à des
ajustements quelques petits changements
notamment
donc en fait on a d'abord jusqu'à
maintenant on faisait des courses de
région donc c'est un niveau moins
important et donc là on s'est mis dans
une logique de recevoir sans pilote qui
est beaucoup
ces deux jours de compétition c'est des
règles de sécurité beaucoup plus forte
donc faut savoir qu'une voiture ça peut
être très dangereux quand elle est lancé
à pleine vitesse
donc il est intéressant de mettre en
place toutes les règles de sécurité pour
protéger et le public et les pilotes et
les ramasseurs qui vont être sur la
piste on m'a quasiment ajustement de la
piste c'est un nouveau membre
christophe qui participent à
l'organisation et qui testait justement
la piste pour vérifier que tout allait
bien donc on l'a dit une centaine de
pilotes sont attendus pendant ces deux
jours alors comment va se dérouler
l'organisation de cette journée donc
l'organisation donc ces deux jours comme
on l'a déjà dit précédemment la première
journée en fait on commence le samedi
matin dès 8 heures et on lance qu'on
appelle les essais libres
c'est un peu comme de la formule en fait
on a quatre manches d'essais libres le
samedi matin les pilotes vont tourner 12
par 12 sur la piste là et l'après midi
on est en essais chronométrés ça va
définir une grille avec les meilleurs
pilotes le classement suivant les pieds
de le
le nombre de tours réalisés et le temps
réalisé et le dimanche matin on fera
comme au tennis le 64e les 24 et 30 2e
26e huitième quart et jusqu'à la finale
qui aura lieu vers 16h30 17h le dimanche
après midi
dimanche après midi c'est les meilleurs
top niveau on va parler un petit peu de
cette discipline parce que même si ce
sont des modèles réduits ce sont de
vraies voitures de compétition la
plupart valeur plusieurs centaines de
romans
quelle est la particularité où la
difficulté d'être pilote de voitures
radiocommandées
il ya deux difficultés déjà en fait on
modélisme on passe à peu près la moitié
de son temps à faire de la mécanique ont
réglé la voiture pour qu'elle soit elles
correspondent à son pilotage certain
nombre de choses la voiture en fait elle
fait 3 kg 5
elle fait 3,5 centimètres cube le moteur
et les moteurs et le cadre de tournées à
peu près jusqu'à 35 mille tours minute
ce qu'ils sont des moteurs très très
rapide et pour entraîner ses petits
moteurs il c'est un mélange spécifique
et à base de méthanol nitrométhane et 8
de synthèse et donc des moteurs qui est
des gages à peu près une puissance de
2,5 chevaux ou qu'il faut régler il faut
que ce soit super précis et derrière
donc au niveau mécanique il y à des
réglages moteur il ya des réglages de
transmission il ya plein plein de choses
qui font qu'un pilote peut être plus ou
moins bon si sa voiture est bien préparé
il n'aura pas d'avariés mécaniques donc
il va gagner les deux temps sur la piste
donc c'est tout ça qui est important
c'est comme ça des pilotes de très bon
niveau tout les toutes les défaillances
mécaniques ont un impact très fort sur
le classement et en pilotage pur on
n'est pas dans la voiture
les réactions donc on pilote
on est à trois mètres de hauteur et la
piste a fait 250 m de développer donc en
profondeur a fait plus de soixante
mètres
donc on n'est jamais dans la voiture et
le rôle du pilote c'est bien de ce signe
merce s'immerger dans la voiture et 2 et
2 et d'imaginer le comportement de la
voiture en fonction entre les pilotes
connaissent parfaitement la piste ils
font une reconnaissance visuelle pour
aller voir où sont les défauts de la
piste un seydou tout terrain donc à des
défauts sur la piste ils les connaissent
et ils vont en dessous et à adapter les
trajectoires en fonction de justement
comment est-ce qu'on se prépare en tant
que pilote pour ce championnat de france
notamment
donc sur un championnat de france
généralement les pilotes y arrivent très
tôt
dès le vendredi après midi là ils sont
là et puis ils vont avoir en termes de
concentration c'est comme des pilotes de
top niveau ils vont tous ceux ils vont
faire de la reconnaissance le matin ils
vont marcher au tour sur la piste pour
la voir pour vous sentir la piste et si
imaginer quels sont les bons réglages
quels sont tous qui va aller bien pour
faire une course impeccable et appuie
décision à son père voilà la précision
est importante et les quatre califes
libres du samedi matin qui permettent de
les chercher les meilleurs réglages pour
voir parce que les pneus compte lui dans
les amortisseurs compte l'huile dans les
différentiels compte voilà ça va être un
atelier de mécanique de mécano tous
samedi matin il va vivre tout le monde
va chercher ses meilleurs réglages pour
avoir le meilleur pilotage et les
meilleures trajectoires
le public est attendu en courant pour
encourager tous ces coureurs petits et
grands peuvent venir des scènes sur
l'entrée libre
il faut venir voir c'est un spectacle
magnifique il ya des événements pendant
la course les ravitaillements où les
mécanos sont hyper synchrone avec
l'arrivée de la voiture et en moins de 5
secondes on fait un plein accès des
voitures repartent
voilà il faut les voir c'est c'est un
peu comme en formule 1 mais en échelle
miniature ça comme dans les courses en
taille réelle en fait c'est ça justement
paris merci beaucoup de série d'anneaux
alors avis aux amateurs ou curieux qui
souhaitent vivre une course automobile
en miniature rendez vous samedi et
dimanche sur le circuit du modélisme à
maurepas club s'est situé rue du
commerce un c'est ça c'est ça
loin derrière jardiland dans la zone de
paris ouest le rendez vous est pris
merci encore thierry tanoh
merci roue liancourtois à la fiche
jusqu'au 3 juillet la ville de
guyancourt organise l'exposition sortie
d'atelier
une occasion pour les visiteurs de
découvrir les créations fabriqué durant
l'année par les artistes en herbe de
l'est de la commune mais aussi de
s'exercer à l'art un reportage réalisé
avec toki nirhy lanto
[Musique]
là c'est un livre de contes de de paul
paul il a jamais fait de dessins essais
inscrits cette année pour la première
fois paul et ses petits camarades ont
réalisé leurs contes illustrés à
guyancourt
pendant un an les élèves ont eu carte
blanche pour écrire leur histoire
peintures pastels au feutre à chaque pas
son style un travail guidé par marina
schwarz j'ai voulu les faire travailler
sur leur imaginaire vraiment qu'ils
développent qui s'exprime en créant leur
propre conte fantastique
l'idée d'utiliser le conte fantastique
souvent inconsciemment les comptes
permettent de révéler beaucoup de chose
de soi
donc c'est important pour moi de les
connaître aussi dans leur propre
personnalité en fait pas d'âge pour
s'exposer adultes et enfants tous
partagent la fiche de cette sortie
d'atelier au programme une découverte de
leur production de l'année le mois de
juin est consacré à la mise en valeur
des artistes en herbe guyancourt toi une
tradition pour la ville à guyancourt on
a une vraie chasse avec tous nos
habitants et on a des artistes eux n'est
donc c'est bien effectivement tous ceux
qui ont envie de
d'exposer et bien on leur donne cette
possibilité et on voit des choses
extraordinaires
des travaux mais aussi des animations à
découvrir jusqu'au 3 juillet tissage de
papier carnet de voyage création d'une
oeuvre collective en argile de quoi
susciter peut-être de futures vocations
[Musique]
depuis une semaine la coupe du monde de
football a débuté les enfants ont envie
de jouer même à l'intérieur pas de
panique
mélanie a la solution pour vos vitres
vases et autres éléments fragiles la
panda la sommation pour les protéger des
missions jouer au baby foot et même au
mini baby foot à faire de ses propres
mains voila moi c'est le mien je les
fais un peu plus avant l'émission alors
et environ 40 minutes de préparation
mais deux fois plus de plaisir de jouer
après pour le faire rien de plus simple
une boîte à chaussures des baguettes en
bois des pinces à linge des bouchons en
liège une règle et de la peinture alors
pour commencer j'ai peint le flou en
verre de la boîte on symbolise comme ça
le terrain ont fait de la peinture
blanche ou pourquoi pas du du correcteur
avec mon stylo il faut bien sûr calculé
le centre et sur les côtés de la boîte
dessiner les cages de but et les
découper moi j'ai choisi de prendre un
cutter et comme toujours en avait
l'habitude quand on utilise un objet
coupant
ou le fait qu'un adulte et sans oublier
le plus important pour jouer il nous
faut des joueurs qui sont ici les pinces
à linge
alors deux équipes de cool à la tv 78
sont les rouges qui affronte les jo de
penne bien 3 pince de chaque couleur et
laissez les sécher ou les mains petit
peu de côté si vous voulez pousser la
précision vous est des grands fans
pourquoi ne pas imprimer les visages de
vos joueurs préférés pour les coller au
dessus des pinces à linge et vous créez
aussi votre propre équipe est là après
on arrive à l'étape un peu plus de
technique
un but technique c'est juste parce qu'il
faut prendre des mesures nous faut
utiliser la règle les pinces ne doivent
pas toucher le fond de la boîte
autrement pourra pas les bouger moi j'ai
fait l'erreur sur l'une d'entre elles il
a fait le refaire ensuite toujours que
la reine ont fait les repères alain à
l'extérieur de la boîte de chaque côté
et c'est là que vous allez faire passer
les vagues est huit coups de cutter et
vous pouvez les insérer vous positionner
bien les pinces dessus alors si vous
sentez qu'elle tourne un peu parce
qu'elles sont parfois un peu plus large
un petit point de colle ou de la
peinture aussi quand ça sèche ça marche
très bien
les bouchons de liège sont là les
poignets est la dernière étape et non
des moindres décorer la balle de ton
pong est joué
merci mélanie on se fera un petit match
après 7,8 culture contrat cette saison
après généré qui ferait vraiment à faire
comme ça
merci beaucoup mélanie on passe
maintenant à notre agenda atelier light
painting à la commanderie des templiers
d'elancourt à l'aide de lampes de poche
dessiner des formes colorées dans
l'espace la lumière sera immortalisée en
photo deux séances sont proposées samedi
23 juin à 15h et 16h30 et la fête de la
musique se poursuit ce samedi à saint
rémy les chevreuse ça commence dès 12h30
au lac de beauséjour avec un pique nique
magny les hameaux vous donne rendez vous
à 16 heures à la maison de
l'environnement et enfin dès 18 heures
de nombreux artistes vous attendent à la
batterie de guyancourt cinq scènes sont
installées se tut loisirs est maintenant
terminé merci de nous avoir suivi on
vous retrouve vendredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro et d'ici là très bon
week-end à tous
[Musique]